all right so many major new developments
new information tonight because of a
mountain of irrefutable evidence
pressure is building at this hour for
the Attorney General of the United
States jeff Sessions to now appoint a
second Special Counsel now senators
chuck Grassley Lindsey Graham along with
senators John Cornyn Thom Tillis they
are now joining the chorus that are
demanding that sessions now finally take
action so real crimes that we know are
committed can now be investigated take a
look the FBI and the Department of
Justice were corrupt in my view when it
came to handling the emo investigation
of Clinton and the entire FISA warrant
application process was abused chances
that you get a special counsel in
addition to what's already there I will
be shocked if somebody doesn't see the
inherent conflict in the Department of
Justice regarding investigating it's a
high probability I'm going to use as
much leverage as I can and I think I
have a lot to get the job done and
sources telling us tonight that there is
a very high probability that sessions in
fact will act and that he will appoint a
second Special Counsel this will be a
huge victory for all of you the American
people it is why we have been calling
for a second Special Counsel for over a
year now this investigation is now
reaching a new level and we're told
there will be new explosive developments
unfolding in coming days in a letter to
the AG Jeff sessions and deputy AG rod
Rosenstein well senator Grassley and
Graham they explained exactly why a
second Special Counsel is in fact needed
these scandals directly implicate key
members of the FBI and the Department of
Justice so it makes it impossible for
those organizations to investigate
themselves now key sections of the
Grassley Graham criminal referral
against the fake news dossier author
Christopher Steele now tonight they are
unredacted and Grassley and Graham
rightly are asking the DOJ to
investigate Christopher Steele for lying
to the FBI about his contacts with the
media remember Steele was shopping the
fake news dossier around to everybody in
the mainstream media all these outlets
like the New York
Times Washington Post Yahoo News fake
News CNN oh and by the way Steele is a
foreign actor in bed with phony Russian
sources even he didn't believe what he
printed in the dossier I thought that
was supposed to be bad for America
criminal even that in fact Steele would
be working as a non foreign actor with
Russians to influence an American
election did he ever register with the
US government
now also tonight brand-new news Fox News
reporting disgraced former FBI director
Andrew McCabe this is huge is now
begging top DOJ officials remember he's
a former Deputy Director of the FBI that
he not be fired because starting Sunday
he would begin to get his lucrative
government pension he's set to retire on
Sunday but he's likely going to be fired
tomorrow now the fact that mccabe is
even at this point is so significant and
it means something what mccabe did
something really really wrong you don't
get fired over nothing especially being
the deputy FBI director working at the
bureau for over 20 years and sources are
telling us tonight that mccabe could
face multiple criminal charges
remember mccabe he was put on leave
after the current FBI director
christopher ray remember he found out
what we will find out soon what is being
exposed in the upcoming inspector
general's report and for the IG report
don't think that what mccabe did
happened in a vacuum
remember mccabe didn't do this alone and
the IG report is supposed to cover look
at the list the corrupt clinton email
investigation hillary having that
unsecured server that was stored in the
mom-and-pop shop bathroom closet where
she deleted 33,000 subpoenaed emails and
her aides were smashing devices and acid
washing and bleach pit and then of
course there's the clinton lynch tarmac
meeting with bill clinton that's only a
small fraction of what the inspector
general is now investigating and then
you have what i called the exoneration
before investigation you had Comey
instruct and paige and other top FBI
officials they put the fix in they
concluded their investigation long
before they even in interviewed hillary
clinton and 17 other key witnesses which
by the way goes
against what James Comey said under oath
when he claimed in front of Congress he
didn't reach a conclusion on the Clinton
email investigation until after view
after interviewing Hillary but that's
not true we know it's not true so you
have Hillary she rigged her primary she
has her friends at the FBI then put the
fix in as it relates to crimes she
committed then she tries to influence
the general election paying over 12
million dollars to a guy outside of
America for Russian government lies in
propaganda all to lie to the American
people by the way Robert Muller how
about investigating real crimes tonight
and by the way since we found out that
those Clinton bought and paid for lies
which the FBI they never verified they
never corroborated well then they took
those lies to the FISA judge and they
used the lies and Russian propaganda to
get a warrant to spy on a member of the
Trump campaign well that then of course
gave them access to trump campaign
communications now remember the FBI's
own protocols and FISA laws it says that
information needs to be verified and
corroborated independently before it
ever goes to a FISA Court judge that
never happened and it didn't happen once
FISA judges will lie two on four
separate occasions this is beyond a
massive scandal and I know the media is
ignorant lazy and overpaid but it's why
Jeff Sessions is now looking to the
inspector general and now looking into
these severe FISA abuses but remember
here's the problem the IG Inspector
General Horowitz he has no prosecutorial
powers hence you need the second special
counsel like yesterday it all needs to
be investigated people need to be
exposed crimes were committed at the
highest levels and people in the end
need to go to jail the full story needs
to come out you deserve that and so much
more from the people that are supposed
to serve you in government all right
also tonight we have breaking news on
President Trump in Russia now it doesn't
exactly fit in the narrative that
Democrats and members of the destroyed
Trump media have been pushing for months
now the Trump administration they're
cracking down on Russia in a massive way
now this morning the Treasury Department
announced
new targeted sanctions against dozens of
Russian entities and individuals
involved in cyber attacks and election
interference in the 2016 presidential
election and that's not all President
Trump he's joining leaders from Germany
in France in the United Kingdom in a
joint statement condemning the Putin
regime for brutally poisoning a former
double agent and his daughter last week
in England now the pair remain alive but
they're in critical condition in a
British Hospital now this all comes
months after President Trump introduced
his administration's first sanctions
against Russia
meant to punish the Putin regime for its
actions in Crimea well that happened
during the Obama years as well as other
human rights violations now of course
this tough policy it does standing stark
contrast to what happened under the
Obama administration and when Hillary
was Secretary of State
remember that lame Russian reset button
that she handed over to our counterpart
and continuing with Obama's total in
action during Russia's hostile takeover
of Crimea despite warnings from world
leaders our own Intelligence Agency and
even congressman Devin Nunez remember
Devin Nunez wrote this op-ed warning
then President Obama about the Kremlin's
hostile actions in Eastern Europe and
elections and warned specifically about
the 2016 elections and the Obama
administration they also dropped the
ball in the Middle East when Russia
boosted the Assad regime and their fight
against the Syrian rebels remember the
redline Assad crossed it and nothing
happened he gassed his own people Russia
supported it Obama stood by and did
nothing
and the Obama administration wasn't any
better on Russian Election interference
according to experts a brand-new book
Michael Isikoff former national security
adviser Susan Rice he issues a quote a
stand-down order to officials developing
an aggressive response to putin's
meddling remember when President Obama
told then candidate Trump you remember
this stop whining you know no serious
person thinks that our elections could
ever be influenced by hacking come on
stop being a whiner
take a look there is no serious
person out there who would suggest
somehow that you could even you could
even rig America's elections in part
because they're so decentralized and the
numbers of votes involved there's no
evidence that that has happened in the
past or that there are instances in
which that will happen this time and so
I'd advise mr. Trump to stop whining and
go try to make his case to get votes so
let's get this straight
there's Obama week on Russians hostile
takeover of Crimea weak on Russia's
support for Assad using gas on his own
people weak on Russia's election hacking
warned two years before the 2016
election and the media is only focused
on Trump's ties to Russia mr. Obama
where were you why didn't you act I've
said it before I'll say it again
journalism in this country is dead it
doesn't exist we break more news here
than all these so-called news people put
together also breaking tonight speaking
of the fake news media they're hard at
work desperately trying to stop stories
about real Democratic scandals the ones
we're reporting because it's going to
boomerang back on them for over a year
the deceitful fake news media in this
country has been flat-out lying to you
the American people day by day hour by
hour and now the biased press they're
employing a brand new tactic you got to
pay attention this spread
completely false information now the New
York Times is claiming to have a
blockbuster story about Special Counsel
robert muller issuing a subpoena to the
trump organization to turn over
documents okay Distillery this
particular story is a definition of fake
news it's a smear to damage the Trump
administration and here's why take a
look at this statement earlier today
Trump organization since July at 2017 we
have advised the public that the Trump
Organization is fully cooperative with
all investigations including the special
counsel and are responding to all their
requests this is old news and our
assistance and cooperation with the
various investigations remains the same
today Oh old news recycled by
pathetic liberal lapdog media so-called
journalists they have wasted 14 months
beating the drum night after night night
after night day after day hour after
hour about a conspiracy theory none
exists no evidence exists it's been a
big lie and the media's deliberately
spread false information and propaganda
which is exactly what Putin and the
Russians want isn't that what they
wanted to do so discord in America all
the media seems to care about is
damaging and destroying president Trump
D legitimizing him
and they're also trying to draw the
president's attention away from the
massive Democratic scandals and not let
anybody else in the media focus on cases
where we actually have real evidence
that's incontrovertible real facts real
evidence and as for robert muller
special counsel this latest leak is not
surprising what Muller is doing is
deliberate this special counsel his team
of Democratic donors Hillary donors
Obama donors DNC donors they are
selectively leaking daily to the media
to keep President Trump off balance
Muller doesn't care about the truth or
evidence or facts because he's been on a
witch-hunt look at the team he's put
together and the leaks are obviously
intentional because it happens every day
and if Muller really cared about
uncovering real crimes real wrongdoing
Muller you'd be investigating them you
know if Muller is gonna keep expanding
his mandate why does he focus on the
Clinton bought and paid for
Russian dossier with Russian lies does
Muller not care that Hillary paid for
this Russian propaganda and she did it
to influence an election does Muller not
care that Christopher Steele is an
unregistered foreign agent who hates
President Trump does Muller not care
about the FBI lying to a FISA judge not
once twice three times but four times
using an unverified dossiers the bulk of
the application to get a warrant from
FISA judges to spy on a campaign
associate so they have access to
everything in that campaign does Muller
not care that this FISA warrant likely
gave access to all of Trump campaigns
communications
an election I can go on all night does
Robert Muller certain do you really not
care that Clinton fixed and had fixed
for her that email investigation and we
know crimes were committed or the
unmasking scandal a three hundred and
fifty percent increase in one year or
the uranium one scandal you and the FBI
director at the time we had an FBI
informant that had infiltrated Putin's
criminal scheme to control America's
uranium well you have no problem going
down every other rabbit hole mr. Muller
why don't you look into these scandals
this is why we need the second special
counsel someone that is going to leave
from the outside this swamp you can't
have people involved in these scandals
investigating themselves that means
Muller that means call me all does they
have these friendships going on here Ron
Rosen see they're all BFF old colleagues
you really think they're going to hold
themselves and each other accountable of
course general attorney general Jeff
Sessions you know he created this
Special Counsel witch-hunt now he needs
to fix it you can't be confirmed the AG
and then the next day recused yourself
and by the way cite the wrong law as
greg jarrett pointed out last night we
need the second independent prosecutor
now sessions knew he was going to recuse
himself he never should have accepted
the job as attorney general look at the
chaos that as a result of all of this
here's a key fact if greg jarrett
pointed this out this is where we cite
session cited the wrong law as the
justification for recusing himself he's
the Attorney General so the burden of
all of this that is dragging this
country down falls squarely on Jeff
Sessions shoulders tonight mr. Attorney
General do your job and fix the mess you
created and also tonight another damning
report about James Kobe's incompetence
and his highly questionable conduct
while leading the FBI friend John
Solomon reporting that the longtime head
of the FBI telecommunication
Surveillance Unit is saying that he
warned James call me about how that
particular spy program was dangerously
ineffective in catching terrorists Comey
never tried to fix it that's
Obama was warned about Russian collusion
and influence our elections it did
nothing and laughed at the idea here's
what the retired special agent told John
Solomon take a look I believe that the
program as it was was ripe for potential
abuses regardless of how it's abused but
it could be and frankly I I see what's
what's been happening in in the last
year and a half and that just proves the
point that this program could be abused
and that it would not be used for the
purposes that it was intended for